Google+ is shutting down you probably
already heard this but I want to talk
about it a little bit and you know along
with it's shutting down has come a lot
of jokes it's look guys I is it funny
is it well I saw someone saying
something about a now being called
Google - I thought that was good all
right well let's look at the news let's
go over a little about what happened
here let's see here we go from the
indiatimes alphabet shuts down Google
Plus after a giant user data leak so
apparently their data they leaked like
half a million users data they did say
that they didn't detect any anyone
actually using the data but whose how do
they really know that I guess by false
logins or something so they just decided
instead of fixing it that they're just
gonna shut everything down which I
totally understand cuz yeah I was not a
very popular social media thing I know
some people tried to use it had some
friends that tried to use it I tried to
use it quite frankly I just forgot about
it like I was using it for a while and
one thing I really liked about it people
seem to share really high-quality images
on it so I was often getting like sweet
nature backgrounds and stuff from it but
other than that I never really used it
and yeah I basically just totally forgot
about it after a while just forgot it
existed but it started up in 2011 it was
pretty big deal at the time introduced
circles which was a new thing it seems
like a lot of social medias adapt to
that especially Facebook now you can
choose exactly who you share with and
you can make your own groups very
similar to circles so they definitely
had some effect on the social media
genre
I guess we'll call it a genre let's see
they said it was a software glitch
they did a major redesign March 2018
okay so they're they're given a little
wine down period so people people can
get their data and all that stuff so
it's not actually gonna go fully off
until August 2019 I believe yeah so
let's get to the fun of this let's let's
check out some of the jokes people made
I think it's enough about what happened
maybe there's more did I miss something
let me know in the comments if I miss
something here here's another article
shut down but that's not what you need
to be worried about what it wait what is
it what do we need to be worried about
okay so I guess the whole problem was
the old gift permission thing was giving
too much access to data didn't Facebook
just have this problem where they were
giving out too much data to the third
parties so that's like this the breach
they seem to be citing and rather than
deal with it and go the Mark Zuckerberg
route of showing up in in court being
like whoo we will reshape they're just
gonna be like we're done we're cutting
it off which I get it seems like a lot
of stress so what do they say we need to
be worried about I'm not gonna read all
this maybe just the first paragraph here
the reason given was significant
challenges in creating and maintaining
successful Google+ products that meets
consumer expectations okay so that's the
breach was the reason that hits the
headlines but really it's just not
popular it just doesn't seem worth it
for them to keep it going so that's the
true reason the reason it seems like not
know so maybe that maybe the data breach
prompted them once they realize they
have a lot of work to do and they need
to put a lot of money into it but that
doesn't seem to be the underlying cause
of why it's shutting down
it seems to be shutting down because
nobody uses it I'm one of these articles
I don't know which one maybe it was one
this is Indian Express well has every
article about this from India
- only India people care no one in
America uses us only well they did say
one
these articles that they noticed
basically that individuals weren't using
this on their own but a lot of companies
or using it as their internal like
social media they would make a circle I
think for their business and have all
their co-workers join and that way they
could all stay in in touch with their
work stuff through Google+ so it seemed
to have some pretty big popularity and
the industry but not so much in personal
stuff all right let's see what else we
got
we want to see the jokes here we go so
we're gonna for the rest of this video
we're gonna look at it's raining Google
jokes and this is also the Indian
Express I just googled I think what I
googled is Google+ shuts down and like
all the top articles or from these
Indian Express websites all right I'm
not digging super deep on this if
there's more to that I'm missing leave a
comment let us know we'll do a follow-up
if if there's a lot more than I'm
missing here press f to pay respects
okay let's just scroll through some of
these that were on this article I'm
gonna miss this place
in my weight in my three point six five
million followers Wow grandpa I found
this and your old stuff what is it
Google+ sits down I'm going to tell you
a weird story really people misses that
I don't think that's very funny I mean
it's it's nice that it it's it's an okay
mean I give it a crap out of crap it's
not a great story it's just not was it
ever really alive
and nice art well let's see this
everyone on Google+ mark migrating to
Twitter oh I've seen this this
my favorite things ever this guy playing
what is this a piccolo and all the
records is coming congregating around
this this reminds me of another rant but
the whole people migrated anything okay
so there's like there's so many
different social media networks I tried
to make a list one day of like all the
social medias stuff I should be keeping
up with and it just kept growing I got
like on there's like Facebook YouTube
statuette Instagram and Twitter and they
just get there's just more of them kept
coming up like if you want to be
relevant you got to post on all these
different social media stuff I know like
some really famous people and actors
like only used Twitter strictly Twitter
and nothing else so maybe that's the way
seems to be a pretty strong standing one
but I know a lot of people have like
personal friends on Facebook and they
can't just get rid of it without causing
a bunch of drama and they're like so
everybody's like where'd you go and you
know all that stuff I'm really annoyed
by social media in general I try to use
it just to like you know keep my friends
and family updated but I really don't
like doing it I have to force myself to
do it I'm hoping YouTube will feel a
little different to me because I don't
necessarily know everybody that's
watching it's more of like you know
people that are interested in the topic
will watch the video not just I don't
really do so much vlog and I guess maybe
a little here and there well like the
whole story thing like everybody wants
to adapt their story everyone wants to
do their temporary story it's on the
instagrams on snapchat it's on Facebook
they all just like what it did snapchat
started I think they started and then
Facebook took it over or adopted it and
so did Instagram
and I don't know the whole thing is just
annoying it's like okay so which one do
I share my story on do I gotta share it
on all of them
do I gotta just post my story on all of
them or just one of them but if some of
my friends only watch one of them but I
want to share with all my friends and
everyone's all scattered it would be
nice if there could be a cohesive single
one I guess is what I'm trying to say
and I don't know the answer to that I
can't seem to only use just one because
then I'll miss like you know half the
important stuff okay well let's let's
continue with these I haven't seen the
Google - joke yet good one else we'll be
shutting out social media site Google+
infecting absolutely nobody at all
it doesn't really affect me I'm sure it
affects some people obviously but I get
the joke that nobody uses it
Google hosts user base in one picture
there's one cents less doesn't oh my
gosh did you know it'll one footage is
of no concern
all right well they're still there so
time there's still like ten months you
got ten months of Google+ left Plus
ready now I'm shocking Google+ had a
half million users even more shocking
Google shutting down it is trending on
Twitter and saintly shocking now that
Google+ is going away I still want to
reclaim the plus operator for the web
search to require that term and the
results nice all right I'm sure there
are tons more jokes let's see if there's
any any more good ones here before we
called the day on the video it's finally
happening myspace behind Google all the
ones in the past his myspace still
exists let's check it out
I think it's still actually up
like if you once had a myspace account
like if you think my space now sucks oh
it's still here what is my space now
oh god this is ugly front page
yikes looks like a news website maybe it
is the best music and culture all in one
place
I have never heard a musician talk about
myspace ever well not since like 2003
2003 2004 it was the last time I heard a
musician talk about MySpace so what are
they doing our musicians actually on
here so use SoundCloud I don't know you
tell me what do musicians uses these
days they just post things on YouTube
that would probably be better than
MySpace why is this this is the front
page it's just like a smorgasbord of
nonsense of clickbait wow this is not
how I remember MySpace at all jeez it's
the music videos people so it's like
they're trying to do a professional
thing here alright well that's it that's
it for for this video
goodbye Google Plus you will be sort of
missed I will I will miss stealing other
people's photos for for backgrounds but
other than that it's just I'm kind of
glad in a way to be perfectly honest I'm
glad when any social media company goes
under because just the thing I said
earlier like I don't want to have to
deal with hashing over okay where should
I post what should I put what should I
post on all of them if I'm gonna post on
Wando I got a post on the rest just to
make sure I'm getting all my friends
with my update just why can't we just
keep it simple and have one that works
good I don't even care what it is like I
honestly think Facebook and Twitter are
the I mean they're obviously the big
ones they're obviously the giant
instagrams in there too but they're
owned by Facebook anyway and I don't I
say I'll have their their niche but I
don't maybe it's those three I was gonna
go with something here about cutting it
down to just one but maybe that's not
entirely possible maybe it maybe those
are the three snapchats still up there -
music alley music musically get out of
here none of that crap don't even don't
even mention it don't just don't do it
alright well that's it for this video
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
let me know what you thought of this
video let me know if you want to see
more like this
anything else did I miss something did I
miss some glaring issue here please let
me know if I did and I'll see you guys
next time peace out keep coding so weird
[ __ ] peace sign huh